Kevin I want to start with you because
you're here obviously you've always been
a part of this show but I know you're
actually you're actually back riding
your back getting into it
what has it been like for you to kind of
get back into like the mindset of these
characters really delve into this world
well you know i yeah I've never been too
far away because I I've been I wherever
Julie is I'm usually five feet near her
somewhere but um I love it you know as
Julie and I sat down to write the first
episode of season 8 together um I was
freaking out like oh man I don't know
you know I was Julie goes you write all
the Damon stuff and I'm like and I was
like I don't have this voice anymore I
don't know anymore know how to do it but
um actually it came back pretty quickly
and Julie and Ben together I think we
with a good writing team I think we got
a great season eight planned out I'm
very excited about it it's really nice
to live in this world again yeah Julie I
know you had talked about you didn't
know if there was gonna be a season
eight when you wrote last season's
finale obviously there are still major
cliffhangers there are still things
happening but so does it feel like even
a little bit like you have kind of a
clean slate other than a few things
you've got to carry through in terms of
what to do this season yeah I mean we we
made a real effort to make sure that our
finale last year had all the closure it
could possibly have just in case the
worst happens I would just thank God it
didn't define the worst too many too
many things too many swear words so for
us it was being able to resolve
relationships and then just tee up a
hint of a new villain and a new problem
and so we really got to start very fresh
this year and it's been a lot of fun
beginning with that does this villain
have a face what can you say about it
the villain has a finger so far other
than that um it's a it's a new take on
villains for us it's definitely
something that's rooted back all the way
into sort of ancient times and other
than that I'm gonna have to let you guys
wait and see for yourself
sorry yeah this big big spoiler if we
started talking about the methought it's
a really great mythology it's a really
great
um I think it's I'm actually very
excited about it so I hope you guys are
too for Ian and Michael you guys
obviously are off doing god knows what
we've seen a lot Enzo and Damon let's
just clarify yeah yeah that's also
visible to me and Mike let's just
clarify Enzo and Damon doing some gnarly
[ __ ]
shocking Kevin's back we've seen like
humanity lists vampires we've seen kind
of a ripper version of vampires but how
does whatever we're calling what's
happening to you too how does that
differ well there's there's kind of
mysterious selling elements of almost
mind-control going on which we haven't
haven't really come across before and
that's all we can really say on that
department but it's really really
interesting how it's playing out I'm
super stoked about this season we've
read up to like four episodes so far the
cast and it's ripping you're gonna love
it
yeah the mind control thing is actually
quite interesting because ultimately
you're used to seeing Damon or Enzo or
any of these characters exert that power
onto someone else and so when you see
them ultimately in this realm where they
literally have no control over their
actions yet I will give this little hint
don't slap me but very you know like in
their minds there's still them so it's
that conflict and that struggle is what
we all sort of look for and it's truly a
gem as an actor to play glimmers of
humanity so to speak cats how is accent
how is Bonnie coping with losing both of
them and her magic that's a great
question um that's like losing your
purse your phone your wallet and your
keys and your child and your
I mean and yes that do you know a lot of
last season was about the development of
the relationship that Bonnie had with
Enzo and and obviously Bonnie and Damon
and you know you see the crumbling in
the season finale of her and you know
she also doesn't have her magic so the
thing that made her feel like herself
and also her best friends are not there
so you start the new season and you see
that and wanna it's gonna be really
exciting to see Bonnie's journey this
season and to see where she she's
literally a Ground Zero yeah Paul for
you does this feel like a little bit
like a reverse season three like Damon
made the sacrifice he's gone off he's
doing crazy things
you're theoretically trying to find him
yes are you trying to fight the sevens
just crying constantly missing his bro
his broham um he's always just concerned
for Damon and it's it is kind of you
know it's back to the original dynamic
of the brothers I mean they were
obviously much more contentious in the
beginning but it's um the dynamic was
always Damon getting in trouble and
stuff and trying to save him and so I
think that in particular you know this
is the case Stefan's sort of normalized
we'll see if how long that lasts but for
at the current time he is he has a
broken heart over his uh bro his big bro
it's big brown slash lover slash level
Candice is Caroline now cuz we saw you
know she broke things off with this one
she still has two daughters is she like
splitting her time between like Texas
and Mystic Falls what's going on um
yes she's very busy kind of splitting
time and family life and you know as we
saw at the end in the finale
helping Stefan and Bonnie track down
Damon and Enzo so she's juggling all
those things balls how do you decide
please be aware that many members
journey may be under yeah oh I didn't
see that yes please be aware that
members of Yahoo Jess just got me in
that meeting that just on his action
it's a no they wrote in fine yeah by the
way it's really tiny now you know what I
meant is it in general how do you feel
like motherhood has changed her um I
think she has a wonderful outlet for you
know she has a whole new um department
in her life to be incredibly neurotic
and I think motherhood suits her and and
I think she wants to be safer and her
adventures she now has children to watch
out for and she's very protective and
which is a quality she's had for a while
but I think it's now even more important
to her sure are we gonna see much more
from these these magical children uh
yeah yeah they're they're gonna come
into play very quickly they came in
handy last season uh idea idea okay how
how is Alaric did you ever anticipate
when you took this role that he would
lose his wife and his girlfriend and the
mother of his children and that you'd be
stuck in Atlanta for eight years
I had no idea and I it's it's been it's
been a sad journey for a lark so I'm
hoping over huh
we'll see what about for Matt Davis yeah
there's a bit of like art imitating life
I'm trying to get out of it so what
about for Matt Damon hmm yeah what's he
been that's a good question
ask him I was thinking he and Matt
should start like a grief Club and
that's true
Zack and I already have okay no I'm good
I'm good at least get over here
no but Zack I do want to talk cuz Matt
ended the season seemingly leaving town
what can you say about is he back is
he's still hating vampires where's he at
well as much as I love these people
I think Matt finally had to make the
decision to to let go of that love so
Matt's out figuring out his own life
finally for the first time so more power
to em so are we gonna see him off on his
all night no okay yes it seems very
exciting I'm driving a red truck I don't
have a cop belt on this time so I can
sit in the seat comfortably oh it's not
uncomfortable driving into a sunset baby
he's doing craft services uh filming
Atlanta
Jack's volunteered to grip and electric
I'm very curious in general for you like
Julie and Kevin when you're crafting
this season how do you when you're
deciding what you want your big bad to
be you can essentially do anything in a
supernatural world right how do you kind
of decide what you want it to do one
well I can only speak to like you know
if you look at the eight seasons of the
show and you look at well first we have
you know the vampire comes in Damon and
the person Stefan is he a vampire or not
I don't know but I really love him so
she falls in love with him then comes
the brother he's bad he's really evil
and so he's big and bad and awful and he
wants you know to get these vampires out
of the tomb and save Katherine and then
wait Damon's not so bad it's Katherine
she's the bad now Katherine's bad but
who's Katherine really bad no
Katherine's not that Klaus is bad Klaus
is the really bad
Smouse really bad no he's a hybrid he's
just a ways the black sheep of the
family it's the original family that's
bad and it goes on you just keep you
build your mythology and that's what I
like about this season because we're at
season eight what could that mythology
be what has yet to happen in Mystic
Falls well you're about to find out and
we're all up here just trying not to
spoil it that there is this really great
thing that's about to happen with and
there's this final bad and we've got
this sort of great season eight plan I
think it's a very evil bad eye when
Julie pitched it to me you know from
last year and she said here's where we
want to go with the season I was like
wow that's pretty cool and then I said
you know and I was like you know it and
I I kind of knew a little bit about this
mythology that they were sort of
utilizing and I thought it was such a
clever a cool way to infuse Mystic Falls
with this ultimate evil and it's like a
little cherry on top of the entire
mythology of Mystic Falls and that's
what I love about it and I'm and and so
anyway I think I think Julian where has
done an awesome awesome job with it with
planning out this season and that's why
I'm I know I'm very excited about it so
there you have it that's why in sir the
question I don't even I don't know been
watching you dodge spoilers and that was
fantastic that's so well thank you I do
want to take it back just briefly for
pollen Ian there the scene in season
seven where the brothers have the phone
call conversation seven years in the
making
they finally hash this out for you all
was it more difficult that it was over
the phone as opposed to in person you
couldn't see each other did you enjoy
that aspect of it voice Matthew Thomas
almost norm I was in the hotel room
right Diana says no no you know no this
speaks of knows where's the bar yeah
that was great
yeah that wasn't really really well
relate
Julie um directed the [ __ ] out of that
episodes it was pretty incredible
um right and this guy was so dialed in
loved that script so much script was
incredibly by the way and mind you what
what well you were outside in all that
stuff and in the snow is fake and you
know the snow is fake and yet you're
still freezing yeah it's a really
bizarre thing and I had just come off of
directing my episode so I was total lack
of doodle and then all of a sudden the
next day I'm on set with Julie and I'm
reading behind the monitors I have two
earpieces on and I'm working with Paul
reading the stuff and watching him crawl
through that snow and go through this
emotional journey was cool but the stuff
in the car it was kind of cool that we
weren't together you guys showed up for
each other no that way you nice thing I
was just gonna say we were there
together yeah 22 episodes for seven
years
and you know it's like we always try to
give it our all but but sometimes a
scene comes in or script comes in that
you're just like I can't help I don't
care how I'm feeling I can't help but
like really put 100% of my effort into
this and for some reason that scene even
though you know and I've done thousands
of scenes together literally undreds um
it we both just cared about it so much
um and but it was a payoff for like not
screw you guys okay it was um it was a
payoff for these brothers I think it was
a cool moment and um yeah thanks for
yeah thanks for Neil Neil Reynolds wrote
that yeah you nailed it you and Hill
crushed it yeah
writers in the house yeah Neil crushing
yeah you're really good enough oh well
thanks so were you for cat and Michael
you guys your relationship was a
beautiful part of last season obviously
you got to play a lot of different sides
of it a lot of great scenes
what do you kind of enjoy most about
this dynamic between these two
characters I love how beautifully
intense both of these characters are you
know they've we've seen them go kind of
to the edge
and back and they both could be really
good and they both can be really evil
and they both have these incredible
incredibly redeeming qualities and I
love how passionate their relationship
is I think that's it's really sexy yes
there you have it what are you gonna say
about that malarkey giggity nari I
second all that really I mean I I always
thought that Enzo brought the fire out
in Bonnie and Bonnie brought the
goodness out of an Enzo and I and I feel
like that created this really beautiful
dynamic and groundedness to two
characters that had not really had
effect those those kind of roots before
you know in Firenze oh he he'd never
really had a family at all and so
finding himself in love with somebody
was the thing that meant the most to him
and now it's been ripped away from him
but we'll see how that all pans out we
have a lot of cool stuff coming up this
season too so you guys would be happy
good
Julie you guys did some episodes in
season seven that were unlike anything
you'd ever done you had a Damon centric
episode you really tried new things is
that something you want to continue or
the more kind of I'm not I shouldn't
call them experiments but you don't I
mean are the more experiments coming
well sadly I have not been able to make
my musical episode fly so that's where
all the boys are naked yeah no no just
singing that obviously that's better for
me I think so
like with regret I have to I have to let
that one go but um we are actually in
the middle of breaking the episode that
airs right before Christmas which is our
mid-season finale and we have a lot of a
lot of great sort of Christmas Story
kind of concept D ideas that were a
little bit excited about no clue if
that's what it's going to end up being
but right now it's a lot of fun to talk
about are we for sure back in Mystic
Falls at this point yeah well you know
we start the season back in Mystic Falls
and Damon and
and an Enzo are not and you know so in
that way we've got to kind of work to
bring them back home into the fold of
whether good or bad the show definitely
is still gonna have a lot of elements
out there in the ether but it's very
very securely grounded back home this
year it's all about kind of bringing it
all back home for Candace you talked
about obviously Caroline will be helping
Stefan Bonnie everybody try to find
Damon he's Bonnie's best friend he's
Stefan's brother do you find Caroline
having to kind of be like the
level-headed like calming emotions
person in this triangle yes I but I also
think that Caroline has put a lot of the
past behind her at this point she you
know we saw in the finale that her and
Stefan came together and so she's really
doing yeah really just trying to be a
support system for him and I think
that's a main goal right now is
supporting her love and her children
sure truly how long is that happiness
going to last you know I like happiness
I do I do it happiness is you know when
used appropriately it can be a great
great story when it's using little tiny
bits um you know it's no secret I've
been rooting for this couple to be
together since episode 202 so you know
I'm certainly happy to bring them to
this place where they can live in as
much happiness as they can find in these
moments with all the crazy circumstances
so it's never going to be easy it's
always going to be a rollercoaster but
they do have the connection that's
really important they're best friends
and they and they love each other deeply
and Stefan needs that right now more
than anything and so she's a really
powerful touchstone for him and and vice
versa I Love You Caroline
Love You Stefan
Zac what do you feel like the key to
staying human is
I tell you about to get up in leashing
well not making love to vampires is one
you know Matt's had a pretty stable love
life and I think that's been a big key
to a success um I think the key for Matt
staying human has just been making sure
that his friends who are ironically
supernatural and more powerful than him
making sure they're okay and so somehow
by making them stable he's maintained
throughout as you saw in the end of
season seven after she saved my life
multiple times she basically almost
killed me while I was trying to save her
life you know and so that's that's
that's that's the humanity man so how
long do you all think you would have
survived in Mystic Falls
that's human about a day are there any
humans and Mystic Falls well yeah what
do you think all the background stuff
all the all the background are they all
compelled though are they done being
compelled the other compelled not to
look at Paul remember yeah I know that's
a contract that's the con part of my
deal no one looks me in the eye
cuz you turn to stone B oh you should
see all the little snakes in his hero
hair I would have been eaten real John
right I think he's really had a really
interesting point
happiness little bits of happiness in
Mystic Falls this would be a really
gnarly place to live and yet you guys
want to visit it every week and I can't
figure it out that's not gnarly man good
yeah I can't unless you're talking about
no never mind Kali ever some of the
anyway some of the some of the audience
members are under 18 malarkey oh yeah
whatever by the way I don't have an end
of my name my name is Rory ignoring guys
it's just it just to let you know
but I've seen you roaring love you guys
Julie I know you have always talked
about with this show you want to go out
on your own terms you want to be able to
craft the story how you want to do it
and really put an ending on this at this
point in the series have you picked your
ending yeah absolutely
you know the greatest honor you can have
as a storyteller in a business of
television is to be able to make those
decisions with your peers and with your
friends and with your fellow
storytellers and we all have discussed
it and we've made the decision that this
is it and you guys are here for our last
comic-con because this is going to be
the final season of the Vampire Diaries
yeah
and it's a it's a it's bittersweet and
emotional and we're all going to be
crying about five minutes but we wanted
to be the one to tell you guys first
because you've been with us all on this
run
and
cranial and the fans all around the
world obviously but the Comic Con fans
who are here with a before meeting and
aired you know that some of the people
who are laughing through the screen
because they thought they were there for
my day with me monster trucks or
something and you guys stuck with this
and you came out and you've been with a
solo so we made you something
and you guys are the ones that get just
enter first so we're gonna thank you
we love you
you